the machine learning world has been kind
of
inspired their imagination captivated
with gpt-3
and these language models i thought it'd
be cool to
get your opinion on it what's your
thoughts on
this exciting world of um
it connects to computation actually uh
is
of language models that are huge yeah
and take
multiple many many computers not just to
train but to also do inference on
sure well i mean it depends on what
you're
speaking to there but i mean i think
that there's been a
pretty well understood maximum in deep
learning that if you make the model
bigger and you shove more data into
it assuming you train it right and you
have a good model architecture
that you'll get a better model out and
so on one hand gpg3 was not that
surprising
on the other hand a tremendous amount of
engineering went into making it possible
um the implications of it are pretty
huge
i think that when gp2 came out there was
a very provocative blog post from open
ai
talking about you know we're not going
to release it because of the social
damage it could cause if it's misused
um i think that's still a concern i
think that we need to look at how
technology is applied and you know
well-meaning tools can be applied in
very horrible ways and they can have
very profound impact on that
i think the gpt-3 is a huge technical
achievement
and what will gpt4 be will probably be
bigger more expensive to train
really cool uh architectural tricks
what do you think is there i don't know
how much thought you've
done on distributed computing uh is
there
is there some technical challenges that
are interesting that you're hopeful
about
exploring in terms of you know a system
that like a piece of code that
you know gbt4
uh that might have i don't know uh
hundreds of trillions of parameters
which have to run on
thousands of computers is there some is
there some hope that we can make that
happen
yeah well i mean today you can you can
write a check and get access to a
thousand
tpu cores and do really interesting
large-scale training and inference and
things like that
um in google cloud for example right and
um
so i don't think it's a question about
scales question about utility
and when i look at the transformer
series of architectures that
the gpt series is based on it's really
interesting to look at that because
they're actually very
simple simple designs they're not
recurrent
the training regimens are pretty simple
and so they don't really reflect like
human brains
right but they're really good at
learning
language models and they're unrolled
enough that you get you can simulate
some recurrence
right and so the question i think about
is
where does this take us like so we can
just keep scaling it have more
parameters more data
more things we'll get a better result
for sure but are there architectural
techniques that can lead to progress at
a faster pace
right this is when you know how do you
get uh instead of just
like making a constant time bigger how
do you get like
an algorithmic improvement out of this
right and whether it be a new training
regimen if it becomes um
sparse sparse networks for example the
human brain sparse
all these networks are dense um the
connectivity
patterns can be very different i think
this is where i get very interested and
i'm way out of my league on the
deep learning side of this but i think
that could lead to big breakthroughs
when you talk about uh large-scale
networks one of the things that jeff
dean likes to talk about and he's
given a few talks on is this idea of
having a sparsely gated mixture of
experts kind of a model where you have
um you know different nets that are
trained and are really good at certain
kinds of tasks
and so you have this distributed across
a cluster and so you have a lot of
different computers that end up being
kind of locally specialized in different
domains and then when a query comes in
you
you gate it and you use learn techniques
to route to different parts of the
network and then
you utilize the compute resources the
entire cluster by having specialization
within it and
i don't know where that goes or if it
starts
when it starts to work but i think
things like that could be really
interesting as well
you